[Music]
in that sucks news oops
submitted by JK is number two [ __ ]
real thank you Richard Simmons is being
ordered to pay lawyer fees after his
defamation lawsuit was dismissed
oh [ __ ] so whatever they said was real
no oh the judge said that being
misidentified as transgender does not
inherently expose someone to hatred
contempt ridicule or publicly and
therefore it does not really what was
work no I did yeah obliques how do you
spell it
look Quay OBL yo Richard Simmons
it was always interest to me interesting
to me how he was like a fitness
personality oh yeah yeah let's do it
he's a gay icon right yes Richard he was
the robic guy yep and so he he sued the
National Enquirer and Radar Online last
year for defamation because they
published this saying that he was
transitioning into a woman what's [ __ ]
up which was not I was not sure yeah
anyone that believes the National
Enquirer [ __ ] dum-dum
yeah how do they get away with reliable
sorrel sources but then Germans in his
lawsuit said that a former assistant
whom he said has blackmailed extorted
and stalked him was responsible for the
false claims oh yeah I love all of it
it's like George Clooney had sex with an
alien celebrities over they take it
seriously that they're like I'm suing
you for saying I was [ __ ] an alien
which makes it look even more real yeah
maybe they just make things so
outlandish you Kenny Masood yeah the
National Enquirer has [ __ ] like [ __ ]
Gwen Stefani likes to [ __ ] motorcycles
right something random true and then
shows are on a motorcycle yelling yeah
you do have pictures
it makes it credible huh yeah and they
were claiming that cute transition from
male to female including shocking sex
surgery breast implants hormone
treatments and consultations on medical
castrations which Richard Simmons saying
that's all false and that they published
these stories were calculated malice but
I feel like the people that do by the
National Enquirer are like 60-year old
ladies at the grocery store that are
just bored with life and then that's
third I don't know anyone that's ever
bought that my grandmother oh really
Connor oh yeah but yep does she believe
it good did she believe it I don't know
I don't think so I think that she just
thought it was fun they still just read
because the stories are some yeah sure
yeah yeah yeah I remember her going wal
on being choir said like I've never
heard her say that in my life like she
would just got it for fun for the
funsies maybe we should subscribe to and
just get delivered she might be really
funny like the onion maybe that's how
they're still in business you make soup
or buying it just cuz they want to have
to me it's like Mad Magazine mmm my god
oh not to me though but there are people
that probably believe that [ __ ] though
and for some reason I think they all
congregate and live around the trailer
although national choir has broken like
like maybe three stories like whoo I
can't remember
I let Kanye West yeah they broke like
three of them three big ones it was like
it's so specific that you know that yeah
I can't remember i just relized remember
some vaguely scenes like the Michael
Jackson shaking a baby off the cuff to
go has he ever came out not that this
matters but just growing up I always
wondered ah well unquote me up I don't
know what gay was I was just like why is
he so different from all the other boys
that I see on TV he's a white guy
laughter oh yeah that you thought that I
couldn't figure out if it was if he was
a boy or a girl I know he was a boy I
knew it was a boy I do not know but did
he ever come out as being gay
Richard Simmons yeah well if he said he
wasn't gay I'd laugh in his face and I'd
be like you're [ __ ] up just nothing
again I don't even know what gay wasn't
I used to watch him I just mean either I
just knew he was just different from the
other I didn't know he was different I
just thought it a core hair like if you
say they've said he wasn't gay that's
like kind of [ __ ] up deny that [ __ ] I
know what gay gay was cuz I had a friend
who always wanted to play the
the wife or the sister it is a guy yeah
did you also play Yankee dick no Yankee
dick can we talk about that for a little
bit
oh no no neither have I did anybody ever
do that cookie one cuz I always hear
urban legends about it but I never met
anyone who do cookie one what is that
we're all the dudes to jerk off on a
cookie and then whoever's the last
person has to eat it or some [ __ ] some
white people [ __ ] what's white about it
everyone jacking off the [ __ ] you never
checked off with with your buddies no no
I mean I don't know about that buddy
I had a Mexican friend that jacked off
on a tostada
in a room with his homies you know and
junior high yeah I think that's a
Mexican thing he's very like yeah
because you know who taught me that
stuff my Mexican friends taught you what
stuff jack off in a circle jerk what was
in a circle jerk was just hanging out
watching porno and jacking off together
see so how is that white how is that
white that makes it white it's the
channel it's a parent's care about them
and actually bake them a cookie I see
yeah active those chips ahoy yeah cuz if
it was a spam musubi then that's the
asian thing those chips ahoy cookies
undermine let's continue oh wait here
wait you mean you're an Asian guy who
likes to chip so why don't blow up a
narrative apart but no I couldn't I
couldn't have Chips Ahoy because all the
other white kids would bring him to
school and I just envy them Chips Ahoy
is this cos thing that [ __ ] tastes like
a chemical cookie I love that she the
microwave a little bit no no you get the
ones that are already pre soft bud
what yeah David you chose the diet at
the wrong time right I'll tell you this
though you died those are the ones in
the red package right the blue one yeah
the red package well I know my cookies I
love cookies yeah but I like the white
Wonder Bread I used to be envious and I
[ __ ] always got it but all the [ __ ]
white kids we get the ham and cheese
sandwiches with it and I wanted that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you ever have the potato
bread no friends bomb it's [ __ ] too
but that's the adult version of it it's
BA it's the one that [ __ ] it's big
right hey stop this fire big saw if it's
got like little powder on the edge for
some days
missiny used to get that roman a sweet
bread
remember that Oh take my childhood
please wrapper right my mom was the
Baker on whacked out there
my mom would bake bread my mom's burg
yeah but your mom probably did a really
great job this one over here really this
wall that's a date national prep
machines are dope - your mom made a
bread machine - right yeah my mom had
walnuts and [ __ ] dates and [ __ ] that
in Italy carrots [ __ ] of the bread
my mom would make like cinnamon raisin
bread Oh loaf of bread there's so much
[ __ ] wack [ __ ] in it when you cut a
slice and you held it to the light it
look like a stained glass window oh wow
B piece of carrot a [ __ ] date [ __ ]
random [ __ ] she was exploring wasn't
she's like the trail mix of bread there
yeah all right so I tried googling
whether or not he is gay like to confirm
it and I can't find anything I don't
even know Google and I know he's gay
well that's dr. Goa dude you got him
good doctor all I was asking is if it
was confirmed I know we all have our
speculations I do comfortably got a
smooth ball no Jesse ever came out how
would his butthole smell tell you
determine his sexual orientation Bart
this is not like semen oh well what if
he Dirk's up himself that leaks on his
butt what is it what he's doing that
like website Oh
what if he's a top and not a bottom Oh
guys guys you need to smell his dick and
his [ __ ] cuz he might be a top ballad
song that came out let me smell your
dick oh yeah oh that was a great song
I'm saying that song I don't know no one
famous who's the one hit why I think it
was reality is a clammy smell yeah
k-love told you great song
play it Tiffany she was suspecting her
mana cheating and the only way she could
confirm if he was cheating is by
smelling his dick you know if Richard
Simmons came out and he said like I am
not gay
that's a uphill battle for him you know
that's definitely another man yeah he
maybe he's a closeted gay icon yeah that
could be it and was it about him I know
there's a couple of people who I thought
who are super gay but they weren't
whoo-hoo I'm not gonna tell you until
after the show oh I thought like famous
people guys gonna hear the couple
college news that I knew they say they
want game they turned out to be pretty
gay those are R&B song this is a
beautiful version oh wow I like I like
the the [ __ ] what he called the harp
that was a nice touch let me smell your
dick that's tight dicks do not smell
nice they can yeah David no I mean if
you wash it directly and then
immediately I'm pretty sure it might
stick doesn't smell bad but then you
told me it smelled horrible horrible Wow
I forgot we said once you just leave it
there it'll start thinking it depends
you got complimented your dick smell any
stupid [ __ ] yeah asked you when I come
out right out of the shower does my dick
smell fresh and he said that's not what
I said I said it still has your smell oh
that's one say you had a smell there's
that dick smell doesn't it I love the
smell of desert goes buzzy are you are
you gay mm-hmm cuz yeah it's just the
way that you said it yeah you look all
the exclamation point everyone knew that
you like [ __ ] yeah yeah I always get
afraid of that no is because we're on
the same topic and then when you told me
raccho not on the same topic know when
you talk about Blart
stepping out of the shower and you smell
in this day I didn't talk about dirt
myself we're just stepping out the
shower and I smell that [ __ ] and I said
oh the aroma is nice if you give him
this spray can you spray it all around
the room right i [ __ ] put it on me
like my [ __ ] Cologne hell yeah I just
be like you could get a jessica's plus
inch handle you would light it in every
room in the house wouldn't you my friend
yep you this man right here is in love
pussy-whipped my dear and he also knows
that she's watching the edits hey it'll
get you somewhere hey God where we angle
brother got away every single angle
whatever gets you laid man just [ __ ]
gonna pull on everything everything you
can everything you always say nice [ __ ]
about Nikki she doesn't watch it yes she
does she comments I saw does she mmm-hmm
I love Nikki's [ __ ] tell you something
but Nikki's possible
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]